good afternoon everyone and welcome to a
another live podcast webinar of the
recruitment rollercoaster thank you for
joining us today on a very very sunny
afternoon so if you're outside in the
garden if you have a garden hopefully
you can be soaking up some vitamin D
while you're enjoying this so I'm
delighted to be joined by and Tony Bates
who's going to be co-hosting this with
me today yeah thank you Tony and would
do a very quick intro in a sec and
obviously delight to be joined by Neil
Qadri co-rec and and thanks your time
Neil we really appreciate it
i Ashok Tony really pleased to be here
as important we all talk to each other
in these changing times
most definitely so very quickly before
we do a very sort of quick intro just
housekeeping for everyone and I just
want to let you all know how you can
best engage with Neil and and also me
and Tony so you'll have a couple of
options at the top in the chat there
where Marian and Liz have already met
ascend hi oh you're welcome to chat in
there and speak the next the next panel
is is Q&A and what you'll be able to do
in there is submit your question so a
big part of today is gonna be all about
on getting your questions answered and
as we're talking as we're chatting and
you can use that Q&A function to submit
your questions and what you'll be able
to do is click up vote on the questions
that you'd love for us to ask and we'll
make sure we get those asked as well so
what I'm also going to do for all of you
just to help in terms of the context of
what Neil can go into a bit more detail
on or a bit less is I'm gonna submit a
couple of polls in a second which is
just going to help us understand who who
joining us today and to ensure that we
give you as much value as possible
so Tony let's just start you very
quickly just just for everyone's benefit
doing short intro and then Neil if you
fall out with and yourself and we'll go
from there
yeah so I'm Tony Bates I'm managing
director
called idec's consulting we have 45
staff we cover financial services
generally insurance and legal with
offices for offices across the country
Birmingham London Manchester in Glasgow
so issues kindly invite me on after
appearing on his podcast so I'm keen to
fire some questions your way Neal
appreciate you coming on sir to have a
go answering them if you can
yeah and and Neal let's enlighten us all
see a wreck what what do you guys do and
what is been going on in in Neal's world
over the last couple of days yeah that's
a good question see you overlooked the
RAC is the recruiters organisation
basically I talk a lot about your re see
when I'm talking to groups of recruiters
because we're entirely owned by the
members that's 3300 agencies I kind of I
and about 10,000 individuals well and
what we might call in the UK right so
it's about in that but yeah okay all in
the UK although I am on the board of an
organization called the world Employment
Confederation which is the re seized
from all the other countries so we do a
lot of stuff together globally as well
talking to the UN and other banking
informers but we're focused here in the
UK and we're all about making great work
happen okay good and the good that
recruiters do you know we as a sector we
open up achieve opportunities for people
and we help people grow their businesses
that's why I thought I'd put my lovely
work t-shirt on today and that's this is
that this is a campaign that was founded
by our sister Federation in Australia
the our CSA and it is all about
recruiter pride and we should be played
we do a great job and the are the ideas
really here to help recruit her so at
the basic level legal advice training
qualifications we run the awarding body
for recruitment in in the UK that gives
out all the recruitment qualifications
but a really big part of what we do is
also representing the industry to people
outside recruitment okay strangely
that's been a bit busier than normal
over the last few few weeks so our
experience in the last couple of weeks
has been
being massively busy 300 400 percent of
the demand on our timers normal
partially driven by huge numbers of
co-star hub lights from recruiters
trying to work out how to access those
governments Keynes thinking about you
know how do i navigate through what's
happened with demand in my market and
although all those questions that were
probably gone to discuss about getting
on top of your cash flow
I could also but also lots and lots of
interaction with government and you
hinted what what have I been up to you
what everyday I have a daily call with
the heads of all the other sector
Federation's from across the economy the
eyetality Federation the retail
federation and so forth where we talk
about what we need to get through to
government we're doing regular calls
with ministers to to make those points
regular calls with senior officials so
really heavily yesterday on getting the
details of the furlough scheme sorted
out for agencies okay and lots of media
work before I came on to this I was
talking about the furlough scheme and
the loan scheme to the FT and just
making sure that recruitment is heard
that our voices at the table because we
should be proud of you know in normal
times we put a million people into work
as temps every day and find a million
people new jobs as perms every year and
and that that should be our calling card
we we are going to be really important
to the recovery from all this yeah and
and therefore our campaigns it's really
about making sure the voice of approvers
is heard okay so my my sore follow-up
question to that and just just very
quickly everyone before I do and as you
talked a bit about this no I'm just
gonna do a very quick poll with everyone
and so we can start getting just some
insights into the audience today and so
I'll share those with you now and Tony
and when they reply but so just in in a
nutshell then they'll all know you sort
of gave us a really good overview
they're like what what is the actual
sort of Thorat link and purpose or Rhett
being involved the government and have
you met Boris Johnson have I met Boris
Johnson yes I have okay
actually when you think about the
cabinet people are in the public eye
right now the best
storytellers actually not that Boris
Johnson but Matt Hancock okay
so Matt and I were both sports
correspondents on the same local radio
station 25 years ago
Wow and I was the majority sports club
correspondent cuz I did the football and
he was the minority sports correspondent
preceded the cricket and yeah so we were
we were both we both cut our teeth on
comms in the same slightly dodged you
got fully licensed to do radio station
in terms of links to government more
seriously and there's a kind of ongoing
formal link with enter in terms of we've
got an arrangement with vwp on how we
help unemployed people in the in the set
they the government comes to us for
advice on regulation so we cast your
mind back to a couple of decades to
January back in January we were talking
about well how should you regulate
umbrella companies and their use in the
sector and civil servants don't really
understand umbrellas but we do so they
we kind of helped the government draft
bits of legislation think about how you
do things well and it's part of that
there's a there's a policy community
that that we can play in to ensure the
value that recruiters are driving I sit
on the more paid Commission assess the
minimum wage and on the board at a Cass
and those are places where it's really
important recruiters voices are heard
because it's really really easy in
government to assume everyone works like
a civil servant you know the open-ended
employment contract safejump for ten
years paid every month and actually what
for instance a furlough scheme is
showing us is you have to be thinking
about it thinking about people who are
on contract for services you have to be
people be thinking about people are paid
weekly people who are paid variably if
you're going to do things well and it's
the RNC's job just to make sure
government understands that okay I make
sense yeah yes just how you turn a story
to by him but just very quickly give you
context and we're 5050 with and fifty
percent of people do palm recruitment
the other 50% Lee both both contracts
and plan and majority of people with us
today are business owners and the
during people with us today actually
working they haven't been furloughed so
sorry it's been they're tiny but you're
going to have you yeah just on that I
think that obviously the burning
question for for me as a business owner
is I guess he's you know the actual the
furlough scheme that we're talking about
a lot of the questions we've gotten
around what following means obviously
not the ability not to work what does
not work in actually mean could you is
there any clarification from yourself or
the government in terms of what not
working means and what what people are
able to do when the further in or or not
following well this is a good
opportunity time for me to say to people
if you want information on everything
that's going on the first place you
should go is the RI C's coffee table on
our website and I'm offering you a retro
version of that now because you're
getting a new version next next month
when we finally launch our new website
all paid for before coffee'd happened I
hasten to add but the but on there we've
got absolutely everything that we can
give out as much as possible at the time
like this open access there's some
things we because of legal insurance we
have to restrict our EC members but the
advice on there is should be people's
first particle and it's been really
getting really good usage we have 30,000
individual visitors over the last few
weeks
they're staying more than five minutes
so it's clearly cutting through but that
piece about furlough if people are
furloughed they should not be working
what does that mean it means they
shouldn't do anything other than things
which they are statutorily required to
do so if you're a lord director and and
they have to be involved in filing your
accounts they can help you file your
accounts they can do training while on
furlough but you probably have to pay
them for that training at more than just
the they eighty percent so furlough is a
full or not working thing I absolutely
have heard from across the industry that
are kind of more German short time
working arrangement would be better we
haven't got government there yet but
it's a unifying I talked earlier about
that group of trade associations from
across the economy are working together
we all think that a furlough scheme
where you could throw someone for three
days a week would be quite a good idea
that morning we can't do that we're
still working on it what you can do
though is you can unfurl or someone for
a week a month if you if you need them
to to do something in your business well
yeah one of my clients actually been
doing that yeah content it's it's a
merely if you were a business owner
right now a recruitment business owner
what would you be doing personally
that's a good question I think it's
really well first and foremost get
crushed cash because it's you cash that
that will tell you have you overused
park are berries after is and too many
times on these things but my dad always
said turnovers vanity profit is sanity
cash is reality yeah and so first and
foremost I think most business owners
are actually there now is understanding
what we cash glidepath is assuming that
this is definitely gonna last three
months in my last six months or even
nameless so think about what your key
decision points are and then take
advantage of the government schemes as
far as you can furlough I thought I you
know I would encourage people to use
furlough for those staff who for whom it
may make sense for so if you don't have
demand and through coming through and
people aren't involved in your kind of
marketing and your senior client
relationships furlough probably does
make sense
see bills the loan scheme I'd encourage
everyone to have another look at so no a
lot of recruitment agencies looked at
the government back long scheme in the
first few weeks though the sorry that
was launched so it's about in there but
the yeah that was one of the questions
submitted by a Dave Lewis it was is
there any specific advice you have on
firm is trying to access that funding to
be great if you could go into that so
I'll say a little bit no but there's a
podcast that we launched last week on
the RAC podcast channel on our website
which is as me and Simon connington from
bps world who's on the RAC counsel who's
better who's been through the process
and I'm not claiming to add any any
Sheen to that at all but Simon offers
you absolute gold in that podcast about
the work you need to do to get it right
the most important thing with siedel's
is lots of people looked early on and it
wasn't really working the government
retooled it completely it's gone from
115 million pounds - in in the first
three weeks it's no lending 150 to 250
million pounds a day Wow and and well
you find in recruitment agencies are
typically getting funding for or help
with what I think it's primarily about
bridging that gap on their cash flow see
how they do so that they don't build up
a cash position that makes recovery of
the business very difficult if you think
about it intelligently it should be
aligned to your recovery plan and that's
probably the biggest bit of advice I've
got for agency owners which is yes the
world will recover we know the Sun will
rise it will come at some point whether
it's June or September or December or
early next year
your clients will come back I'm not sure
clients will necessarily come back
building the same businesses they had
before yeah so that that advice that we
got we've all heard about getting into
your niche and making sure you've got a
USB that differentiates yourself I think
that's that even more important than
normal because I think I think this
crisis will amplify some changes we're
seeing the sector that big move towards
being more of a professional services
sector where advice and trust with the
client and long-term relationships are
really important to retaining your new
position so if you're if you're in if
you're an agency leader right now get
close to your clients you don't need to
be selling them stuff because they might
not be there but understand the business
that they're trying to build build those
relationships I think those are the
things that will pay you in spades when
it does come back okay I just want to go
back up to the furlough piece alone when
you say no work at all but I think it's
a really it's really vague isn't it so
for example if I leave I load at the
moment am i okay to be connecting with
people on LinkedIn am i okay to be
posting content you know is that is that
clusters work for me recruitment work
he's arranging interviews getting jobs
on sending candidates out so his work
still clusters me posting content to say
how you doing or or connecting with
someone that might be someone I want to
talk to in the future is there anything
you can provide information on that
something that really passive action yes
great for us really as to what what
working looks like and what actually
work is in recruitment yeah that's a
really good question and part of the
challenge for giving a really definitive
answer is of course the I can I can
claim to be one of the small groups of
geeks who knew what fur law was before
corporate profit 19 because it's
actually quite common in the u.s. labor
system okay it's never there's no legal
definition of verbal in our system and
that's why you climb these questions
about what work is I think I think the
the analogy that I would use is paid and
unpaid work experience yeah I think we
all know that if someone comes in on an
internship and is doing stuff that's are
helping to earn you money you should
probably be paying them and in fact the
National Minimum Wage Act says you
should be paying but we also know that
if people do things that are around the
edges of your business and they're
getting experience then you probably you
maybe don't need to pay them for that
and I think that's where we should think
about referral law so I would say the
core productive process that involves
billing clients resourcing interview
scheduling doing the interviews play
client
added value client conversations about
the work that you do with them all of
that off-limits for people on for a long
activity on social media I think is fine
and I don't I genuinely think some of
this is about is about a balance of
probabilities I don't think anyone at
HMRC is going to be auditing people's
LinkedIn feeds for here's an interesting
thing about the sector that I've read
and they might be or they might be more
concerned if they get evidence or we've
got all these opportunities please get
in touch with me yeah yeah interesting
there so based on your experience then
and of talking to
Bojo and all his mates up there and it's
so you've got three weeks you work for
idec's consulting and we followed you
for three weeks
so congratulations welcome to our deck
team I mean it's been a career ambition
for some time but unfortunately we've
got to follow you for three weeks
what what what things are you gonna be
doing at home what would you be doing at
home as a followed consultant right now
well first and foremost well I think we
should all acknowledge that this time is
a big resilient challenge for all of us
whether you equate whether you're
furloughed at home doing very little or
whether you're working every hour God
sends or somewhere somewhere in between
and we're all at home you know trying to
educate our kids while also both doing
yeah I'm trying I'm in this room doing
this my wife's in another room doing a
car doing a call with some of our
students and the kids are downstairs
allegedly doing some schoolwork chancy's
practically zero so I think there's a
lot of just we're not all going to be
that kind of lockdown hero that we see
on LinkedIn much as I would love to I am
NOT going to lose the to stone I need to
lose during and-and-and so we have to
start with what can i realistically
achieve and then after that there is so
much creativity going on and I think you
enter data to me people are not on
furlough during knock down there is so
much content being created that is of
interest to recruiters and will be
helpful as we go back and as we recover
I think dive into that but dive into
into in a way that's sustainable for you
I'm very aware I was reading some
research from that came out China
because of course China's ahead of the
curve on this that week five of the log
dome which is where we are now these are
is a particular challenge and because
you've lost the kind of newness of it
and you can't quite see the the end of
it yet and so I think making sure that
you're focused on things that will help
but you do that in a really sustainable
way because everyone's got five pots to
boil on the stove right now cool yeah I
guess the sorry it's sorry it's not fun
I've shut up in a minute
I apologize man I don't sure your
compost you rot me continue to talk yet
Hey all right thanks ish so yeah I guess
the biggest concern is that we you
follow a number of people
there's our home and you tell them not
not to do anything and their post a bit
of content online and a few months down
the line the government come back and
say they were actually working so we're
taking the money back I guess that's
that's the worry for ourselves and any
business owner I guess and also it's
quite nervous for furloughed individuals
who are sat there that they don't want
to compromise the business as well so
we've got furloughed people that unknown
want to work and then note that the
furloughed you know that want to work
but they're also scared to do anything
in terms of context they don't
compromise ourselves and the business
yeah so I guess that's if you got
anything that you could sort of
assurance on that at all already
anything that can make me feel a little
bit more comfortable or the pilot people
feel a bit more the divet just to add to
that no which is what I was going to say
Tony was yeah people are messaging about
this in the in the chat panel here
Darryl Hugh said yes it's crosses work
it's marketing Melissa Tang is saying
our colleagues have been told no
activity on LinkedIn Instagram not
allowed to like any other colleagues
posts so there this really is a big rare
oh it's so I'm glad you're pushing on it
because it's the business that I'm in
and a lot of people are unsure of this
because of the reasons that Sonny just
said yeah and also you've got a lot of
people from what I see you know we've
one of our competitors our fellow do you
know 60 70 people for two months you're
talking about a huge amount of cash that
that take you from the government in
three months three or four months of
time the government come back and go
actually you were posted online so we're
going to take that money back it's you
know we're back in a situation whether
the business is gonna have to fold in a
few months time because they're taking
that cash I suppose so
so it's a gray area but it's something
that we must I guess we just don't agree
with being there in the bun do we yeah
so I don't know what I guess that's what
I'm asking for yourself is there
anything is there an OP is there a
chance that we could get bitten in
future take the furloughed money and we
get penalized for someone posting and
marketing you know there's even variance
on the queue and I hear from people and
completely different opinions and
business owners so there's definitely
not enough clarity on that what what how
can you help me with my dilemma
so first of all it's a good question
and I don't think any wasn't ever
thought about in this kind of detail but
the difference between the individual
and the corporate on LinkedIn and that's
really where where the line is isn't it
so my first bit of reassurance HMRC's
audit is not going to be protective
particularly focused on more people was
the federal wood staff of putting on
LinkedIn they're going to be they're
going to be focused on people creating
fake employees in Korea and trying to
claim claim for a little cash and that's
that's why they're all RTI event things
that is so clear in the rules because
they're and government's intention is
unlike lot usually when they want to
control where money goes very very
tightly is to get support to employees
who are not being paid by other ways so
you got that so that's that's just a bit
of framing to come to LinkedIn post yeah
I can understand why some agencies want
to take a caution first approach yeah
and and you know um to me that's a
decision that individual businesses will
make what I have said to friends who are
fir Lord is there is a distinction on
LinkedIn between marketing activity for
your business and what you as a
professional in the field are doing okay
I share an awful lot of re-see content
on LinkedIn everyday if I were further
lord I probably shouldn't be sharing
everything they are a secret sect that I
probably could comment on some of it and
as long as I'm sharing other content as
well as my employers content and that
none of the content that might I'm
sharing from my employers is a
thoroughly commercial then I think it's
fine so is that that it's that piece
around are you acting because you are a
professional in the field and you're
commenting on things like I might see
something from the law paid Commission
or from the TU C or the CBI as a as a
lead policy leader and
and say that's really interesting I'll
share that and put a little comment on
think that's alright if you're blasting
out stuff from your employer absolutely
not
I think would be the light ok so just a
quick one so question just as we're
talking about there so question from
Andrew Gibson can you ask Neil what his
advice is around recruitment agencies
now applicable for the business rate
relief and how we go about accessing
this
well thanks Andrea and that was
something we push really hard for it
only applies to some agencies who do
read the guidance it applies to those
agencies who are open to members of the
public from interviews and so forth and
the business site
it applies per site as well so that you
have a rate if you have a branch network
it applies for each individual branch
the first piece of advice is talk to
your local authority so we found out
about this one we got the confirmation
of this Monday two weeks ago I know that
some of the RAC members that got in
touch with a local authority that they
have know been paid so so pick up the
phone to your local authority they all
have teams that are working on this and
work it through with them ok no first of
all before we can all fight a lot of
questions out there I think it's really
great that you've actually got the balls
basing its come on and answer questions
so so fair place except do you think
it's really commendable of these it's
great that you doing it first of all but
that's my pre before I file some nasty
questions that you know I saw that
coming of nails the one thing I'll say
is what I say to you an issue before
which is if I don't know the answer so
I've got I regard it as a strength and
leaders to say I don't know what I'm
going to say no I respect that my areas
for that but I think I've got a question
from a goggle map right and he was
saying what of the rep managed to
achieve to help recruiters through their
political lobbying during Kovan 90s I
guess yeah what's been your achievement
I guess what have you done for us lowly
recruiters well and they were all
talking to Bojack literally just talked
about adding recruitment agencies to the
list of our business rates support
that's really important we worked really
really hard in that first week to get
cjr s set up so if you remember rishi
sunic standing on that platform thanking
the business organizations we were the
recruitment business organization that
he meant and will you have your huge
amount of work in that in that week see
bills we were we were less involved in
because it was really the financial
sector that took the lead with the
Chancellor work on working through that
but what we are finding is you know I
was talking to Nadine's are we the base
Minister last week about some of the
changes that need to be made to make
sure that recruiters in particular
qualify and yeah if you're not kind of
finance being sorry for what I'm about
to say but the debt profile of
recruitment businesses is different to
most businesses because of course what
we do is we have a lot of short-term
debt which is people we've placed in the
template people we placed and and and
have paid but the client hasn't yet paid
us and and so last week I was talking to
the British business bank about how we
how we make sure the banks understand
that recruiters should look different in
debt profile and they've taken that away
to the to the provider the the providers
to see those so it's that kind of stuff
that you know that will really need epin
at the moment nice quick quick question
a great question from Chris shared that
just come through and I've seen a lot of
people post about this I think I mean I
I'm down in the East one at the moment
where I grew up but live in London and
if you were to go in the shed office
space like we work or like the one chris
has put in like runway East you are
going to bump into a recruiter there is
no room in business and every single one
of these offices so Chris is or Chris's
question is our office is a shared space
for runway East in Bristol which is
luckily work-type serviced office and I
have found that this makes claiming the
government run hard don't directly pay
business rate for myself so any advice
will knowledge of what work has been
done for example what has worked because
a lot of people will be in that
situation for sure so rent in general is
open topic for us clearly there have
been
some changes made in terms of the rules
about around commercial leases I think
that but you know Christmas is right the
the the point is sharpest for those who
have spaces of taking spaces in places
like weworks and Regis yeah and that is
primarily unfortunately a commercial
arrangement that you know government is
not particularly keen to get involved in
they say we're delivering the business
rates rebate but of course you aren't
the people who pay the business rates
rebate in business rates yeah it's
really difficult for us as an industry
organization why did a post on the
Argosy blog a couple of weeks ago and
I've written to a whole slew of
organizations jobs boards and serviced
office companies to say can you do
tickly yeah you guys benefit from this
industry and I have benefited from this
industry over a decade of really
spectacular growth and it's on you know
we are they're all come out of this
together or we come out of it separately
and I think particularly for the
serviced office providers let's be clear
the one sector I wouldn't want to be in
coming out of this is commercial
property because yeah Kayson a I'm a
chief executive of a business right
we've got 70 staff i re chq is 10,000
square feet right it's too big for us as
it stands when our lease is up in 2022
I'm coming to 8,000 square feet if you
ask me in February today I'm coming to
5,000 square feet yeah I have seen my
business offer it remotely in a way
there to be honest I didn't think was
possible so it actually comes back to
trust and long-term relationships it is
it absolutely in landlords and Service
office companies interests to reach an
accommodation with you know with the
with with tenants now what I would say
is everyone jobs boards tenants LinkedIn
are really really cautious about putting
a general offer out there because
everyone will take it
whether they need it or not ya go
specific talk to your relationship
manager to your client the person who
deals with you and say look I really
need you to help me out by the way the
RAC says you should help me out
give me my job boss feel free feel free
to premium it premier need I'm happy to
to be the donkey man for all these
things and and just see what they'll do
because I am starting to see people
doing interesting things story from
remember last week about a landlord who
had come in and put up a temporary
divide in their office so that they were
using the space they needed and adjusted
the rent accordingly now that what that
was in a serviced office space get get
the pressure on qlj yeah I think just to
add to that I mean I I just have a
co-worker membership in with the office
group and I reached out to my is the
content I have there and they've Rose my
membership for four months and yeah if
you don't actually don't get right but I
think yeah well answered Hartman
yeah yeah I think it's interesting you
saying that the industry wouldn't want
to be in this commercial property I
don't know that you do a lot of trends
analysis the record so if you were I
don't know there's a guy James Howell
Newton is ask for advice for an agency
startup during this crisis yeah I guess
with the analysis that you've looked at
what areas do you think gonna be this
sort of the growth areas and recruitment
over the next 12 to 18 months or or even
longer so I was on a call with an old
their mind who's no HRD at a charity but
previously was astir and one of the big
rail companies and and the BBC and so
forth and his take was that he and I
agree with this I spent 15 years of the
CVR before came to the RAC and working
with 50 to 58 of these he and I both
haven't met an HR D who isn't cut coming
back to this to accelerate something
that they knew they were gonna have to
do anyway so recruitment will be there
but your clients will be throwing in
different places what do I think that
means I think it's really telling that
across all the sectors that aren't
really
covered fight relevant Logistics health
care and so forth where demand is still
strong because of what we're doing you
know Tesco had 45,000 people in the last
month IT and Technology and science lab
stuff is is actually not done very much
in Assam it's known don't believe the
idea that it's resistant to the fall but
I think ite and particularly things
which are about people's digital digital
user experience and digital journeys
yeah I have I think it would be super
important not least because I don't know
what your experience told me at your
place was we saw the lockdown start
before the lockdown started most
businesses were already shutting their
physical space down before Boris Bandos
at the other end we know from China that
if that when the lockdown ends you know
Boris stands up another ain't a lockdown
I was Thursday night believe me were not
all gone for a curry on the Friday night
no yeah so so that piece arranged how
how has our economy changed lots more
digital lots more things of marketing
for instance I think you'll see the
further enhancement of that long term
shift towards digital if you look into
industries I think it means the trend I
think will be most interesting is how
far the idea of just-in-time production
will be damaged and whether we are going
to see more belief in building up
domestic supply chains so I think for
instance manufacturing might have a
gentle recovery over the next decade I
mean it I think the original question
had an FS and insurance Britain will
remain an FS insure an insurance leader
and it'll bounce back what just can I
just um build onto this so a great
question and I've been speaking a lot my
clients about this because I think I
think it's fair to say that when you
start bouncing back out of this however
that looks like that you might have less
competition so I guess what what's been
so the question from
Fuki sibling was by how much will this
situation shrink the number of
recruitment funds what we being to him
right now
and yeah could the survivors who bested
that to benefit from a less at your own
saturated market when it's all over
what do you think about that so I said
earlier that I think almost like this
around the fire of changes that are
happening I think the best businesses
will rely on the long-term relationships
and the trust they have the clients and
the good financial planning that they've
got to survive I think some businesses
may be struggling a little bit might you
know might not come back especially in
that very small space where they're very
small but not quite niche enough and so
I do I do think that um I think we all
know that the industry will shrink a bit
this year have you seen annual members
and we we haven't seen a lot yet what
what we have seen in a really big way is
it is kind of the beginnings of a big
debate about consolidation I think would
be a lot of merger and realignment
activity as we begin to see the path out
I'm aware that there is finance out
there for some for some firms and
investors who are looking to be
acquisitive okay and and there's that
kind of a logic behind that in financial
advisors saying this is a time if you go
to invest and recruitment business this
is probably the time to be thinking
about it because clearly you've got a
certain generation of owners who are
maybe thinking of exit at this point
when also you've got and we've got
thirty thousand recruitment businesses
and in the UK but actually only about
four and a half five thousand of real
scale I suspect we'll we'll end up with
more of scale and maybe a smaller number
in that thirty thousand in the years
time so then I read today that the
recruitment sector last year was worth
thirty eight point nine billion pounds
that right yeah what what what's the
forecasted figures for post kovita
numbers about twelve twelve pounds well
I did I did see a joke from one of my
council meetings today that the big
measure investors of the
looking for nosey bit DAC which is a big
job but after coronavirus effects but
the I think I said earlier I'd say I
don't know if I don't know and to be
honest that's unpredictable what I would
say is two things one the industry
shrank by to about 18 billion in 2009
from about 25 26 27 and I think that
kind of level of demand is probably not
you know not accept it but the big
difference with this is this recession
hasn't happened in a normal way look if
you go back to your kings and you know
the economy's driven by animal spirits
if people feel bit worried they stop
spending they businesses stop investing
they stop hiring and and you get this
kind of gradual don't turn that happens
over months and actually by the time you
realize you're in a recession it's over
and the recovery starting to happen and
that's a kind of demand driven recession
what we've got here is a supply driven
recession governments are safe to turn
the economy off to save people's lives
the shorter the gap is before we turn
the economy back on the less damaging
this thing will be the longer it is we
have to accept the more damaging will be
because there'll be more unemployed
people and businesses will be in a
weaker position to invest after the
recession that's why all of the business
organizations are not campaigning to end
a lockdown no not like these and not
jobs on the Michigan State House lawn
but but we're saying when we get to the
point where we feel it's possible we
need a really good plan with a really
good plan for a staged opening if the of
the economy and a plan for what happens
if there is a second wave because really
what we'd like to do is get to a plan
that don't means we don't all have to
spend 12 weeks inside if there is a
second wave in October or November
please not yeah and and so that that
that's a that's an enveloping part of
our discussion the government there yeah
so that's good I mean there's a lot of
talk about staged staged return to work
and obviously priority roles would go
back sooner where does recruitment rank
in terms of priorities you think to the
government if we were in terms of a
staged return would we would be first
middle or last did you see that
they say that pitch should share the few
or got shared around from the Daily Mail
obviously it wasn't free a bit there I
don't read the paper though but like the
the red green and orange light system
yeah yeah yeah yeah and I thought that
was the most sensible thing that I've
seen from dominant so far really yeah
but where would recruitment rank really
in terms of you know the phased return I
guess I think the foot the priority
roles would go back first but you know I
guess of you got I guess what I'm
getting at when you think will be back
in the offices no I'm asking you a
question you related to the REC is just
your personal opinion so I'll give you
I'll give you an estimate at the end of
this and it is an estimate and a guess
nothing wrong
where does recruitments there I think
actually we go sub sector by sub sector
there You've member that we have
actually got some recruiters who are
deemed as key workers people working on
site with grease with loose supply
companies doing blue-collar
supply into food manufacturing and we've
been supplying letters of the re see
that people can carry on their way to
work to to show that their key workers
and so I think and and I think we'll see
a bit of that I think when recruitment
goes that probably depends when you're
set with the sector that yours with the
sector's you're serving the core bad
right
alright SAS and I think we're in the
middle basically we all know that
probably there isn't much of a loosening
of the economy until the schools reopen
and I think this schools will probably
be one of the first bits because that
enables people to go to work in a really
substantial way and I think the next
stage will be offices that can open
there aren't
attracting artists into large numbers of
the public and a new classic
improvements I can open in that space
you might still be doing your interviews
digitally but you could you could find a
way to
to bring people back what are they
encourage every time try to have this
call for the re see this one every
recruitment business owner to be doing
he's thinking about if I could open but
the government said to me I had to take
sensible social distancing steps how
would I open so case in point we are
dividing the re-see staff into we have
enough space in the office for half of
the staff to be in and be socially
distant enough from each other and with
the first stage of ours reopening
Dorsett house the rsd HQ will be having
half of the staffing on any one day and
the rest working people and so what's my
planning for over here and then when it
happens obviously big gatherings you
know in the drawer behind me here I've
got I've got two tickets to Wales for us
is Scotland in the 22 26 nations which
was of course famously called off at the
last possible minute last month I don't
imagine I'm going to that game anytime
soon I don't imagine pops or opening
soon I think recruiters can expect to
open before that at a guess I think I
see I see I see the late very late May
and into June is the point where we
start to see things open off good and
show no you want far into some questions
like you from that we sent across yeah
[Music]
gonna say I guess as we're sort of
talking a bit more about what things in
the look like when you come out of this
and these sorts of things I guess know
what what's your thoughts is a question
from Rosie and Marie which was basically
how do you think the recruitment
industry is going to change and after
going through this I think I've I've
spoken to loads of business owners who
if you were to speak to them a couple of
months ago around what's your thoughts
on flexible working those are gone eff
off I want my people in the office but
the hands been forced that they're now
doing that so I think yeah I think what
are your thoughts on our industry the
requital industry and how it's going to
look and be different as we come out of
this well you know we had a model that
was working and for 10 years it worked
really well for lots of people across
the industry and of course when you've
got a model that's working what you tend
to do is you tend to stay in that what
government would call that silver
command space to get the tactics right
getting the marketing right
from there and you don't spend as much
time than the kind of gold command space
of what's the strategy in the direction
yeah I think this forces you into that
space now and case in point the you know
there I need to be able to I of eyeball
my people and look at the whole rigs
well yeah you do you do need ways of
measuring your staffs productivity but
they're probably different and you even
before this we were getting a a
different feel from recruitment agency
leaders about what the expectations on
staff were and how they were changing it
wasn't the industry that I joined in the
90s where you know if I didn't bash the
phone enough claims every day I was in
real trouble almost hit my numbers so
this fight there the the challenge is
[Music]
the challenges that were finding new
ways to be productive and I think the
thing us intensely the earlier the thing
that cuts through for me is how are we
becoming a professional services
industry how becoming more advisory how
we spending more of our time on the
added value conversations with
candidates and think of a candidate
experience and clients and thinking
about client planning so the sensible
business owner is thinking get close to
clients and understand how their
business is changing find my niche that
I can deliver a USP build a team that
can deliver that without me being the
critical point of sale in everything at
all times obviously if you're small
that's it and then on on the candidate
side just think about why candidate
experience will continue to matter ever
more and so think about that through to
and all of the process stuff that we
asked have to do digitize digitized
digitized I think that that package is
probably where people going and all of
that actually you could have said in
January when a driver wasn't there in
the same way because we're because they
know you're our model was we're still
delivered and the thing I done the
example I point do is retail in Britain
between 2005 and 2015 so if you remember
yeah those are
enough to remember the session but there
was a time when Marks and Spencers ruled
the high street really yeah I think I
think will words of that someone say
about that's nice as you can tell I'm
still mourning the loss of always
picking on my are war what come on
Willie so anyway what happened in retail
was they used to be the curb that looked
that was kind of an awkward pointing
arrow and you had a few kind of pounce
treachery shocks on the low end that
people were a bit snooty about and you
had one or two really expensive shops at
the other end and and everyone else
bought bought the pants remarks
dispensers what happened in retail was
we had a massive growth in a in a really
transactional business at one end and we
had a massive growth in high luxury at
the other end which became a bit more
affordable and it was the middle of the
mark of the disappear I think we will
see that in recruitment so one end
you'll have people who are doing
staffing who are doing much more deep
structured supply arrangements with
their clients where they're involved in
helping the client design that where the
margin comes from the level of
throughput or rather than the where the
profit comes from the level of
throughput on the margin and where the
bit there'll be a big pressure on
compliance and treating candidates well
because that's not gonna go away
government is not gonna get smaller
after this I suspect for a while and you
know we're all gonna be paying for the
government support in tax for years to
come and then at the other end I think
you deep specialists high margin law
throughput are going to be about going
to benefit so if I were advising a
recruitment agency or nervously pick
what which one of those you're going to
be I think they're kind of the the day
of the generalist recruiter was already
ending we know that we've talked about
it for years
you know this will this will just be the
nail in the coffin I've never got
another question but Tony don't add
anything to that anything no no I was
question is actually a little bit left
field I guess obviously view it's good
to understand you know the views and and
how the industry works
did you listen do listen to the
recruitment rollercoaster podcast I hope
I have been known to hey III mean in the
interest of fairness I I also do enjoy
brain food on the other weekend okay
what was your favorite episode a much
think the patient was a as a host so hey
he seems a hostess I didn't realize he'd
snuck in on me a presentation the oh
yeah the export unfortunately I I had to
shoe off to meeting with members so I
didn't get to see issue which is one of
my great loss great losses favorite
episode well I mean how could I possibly
pick this was pretty good I like that
guy than the are you see all I wanted to
ask I mean as a question from Amy
and Owens hopefully I pronounced that
right but I think we're talking about
sort of what I'd be focusing on the
positive sort of as you come out of this
for the industry and how it's gonna look
and be shade but think it's a great
question she said what do you see as
being the top three challenges for the
recruitment industry in q4 in q4 of this
year so you spoken as well
yeah we spoken about what we should be
doing and what you should be thinking
about what have been the top will do you
think would be the top challenges in the
next two quarters for recruitment
businesses one understanding the new
normal so I think we there was a lot of
talk when this first started happening
last month of a kind of v-shaped bones
you turn supply off you turn it back on
everything's back to normal
I think it's a it's a softer return
curve so yeah big challenges on right
sizing what you're doing in your
business to the market as it is and not
they're not resting on hope that
everything just return back to normal so
keeping that even as things are
improving in that discipline that we've
learned over the last month is going to
be really important I think the second
one is you know every bit like Sherlock
Holmes with the magnifying glass finding
the demand so getting close to the
clients and understanding where there is
and maybe looking at where there are
other things that you can do back in the
financial crisis of 2008 9 we had a lot
of members who got into things like
candidate advice and and coaching and
things like that so there might be some
some additional services that you might
be willing to offer out placements
another four that you might be able to
offer in your niche that would be
helpful and then I think the third thing
is you own people and not just because I
the furnace team is time limited by
definition if the furlough scheme comes
to an end and you can't take all your
people back on you are heading for
laying people off you see there's that
but there's also the whole survivor
syndrome thing which is with the team
once you've done that right sizing with
the team that you then have how do you
get them focused on on the right things
for the future of the business and I do
think there's a real risk that they're
kind of batten down the hatches get over
the cash hold on to everything tightly
we're not doing the marketing with it
and that that persists into the upturn
and it actually holds businesses back so
and it's about having some confidence
about backing the marketing in the
outreach and the challenge the the
growth potential that you see in your in
your mock and you can only do that by
getting corset pods
nice okay and I think as we saw come to
the end of this I guess it'd be great
just to sort of wrap up really on sort
of if everyone listening right now and
joining those were rec members what what
and what would you be saying to these
people and how would you be
communicating to them what should they
be doing which they'd be thinking about
sort of parting words really for
hopefully future rec members well of
course they all should be re CE members
and we'll be happy to bring them on
board in G&G because we've had six new
members this week which in this
environment you thank you it's not seen
it seems unlikely look there are
receipts out here to help your business
grow and either even when
that's not what your business is doing
we're here to help your business
our advice for one all recessions end
all the a Novak activity returns while
it might not be the time for super
optimism it is a time for pragmatism
right now you've probably got across
your cash flow assume that your worst
case is your core build on that make
some decisions about how you go know and
do that based on spending the time you
have to get costs to your clients we
will do everything we can to help you
with government
we'll do everything we can to help you
to help you in other ways to the most
kind of that's the strangest thing we've
done this week is we've written a brief
to dealing with local journalists for
agencies because suddenly local
journalists are talking to agencies
around the country but one that's a
great way actually to get your name over
there and you should definitely do it
but clearly there can be some difficult
not as difficult tourneys questions but
some dynamical questions that come from
that conference so if you look on the
commad re-see covered up there's a link
that you can email our head of commerce
to to get the re seagate to talking talk
why why do you think why do you think
that why do you think i do now
interested in that we're getting through
the initial shop and people are
interested in you know the jobs market
and how and how it reacts but they're
also wanting to ask questions about
temps and for a long we haven't talked a
lot though the holiday pay issue for
following temps that's something that
we're working really hard on at the
moment and we're starting to see members
get questions about you know would you
would you for a little tense under what
circumstances so that kind of work just
making sure people are well supported to
do their businesses do their business
right when the well when they're talking
to journals or things like that the ice
the re see ultimately is a members
organizations like a building society my
bottom my boss is the chair but the
chair is elected by the members and
there there's no the only profit we make
is stuff that gets reinvested in the RAC
for the good in the industry so the end
of day it's your organization and we do
the things which help you best so get
involved until and tell us what those
things are because while it's a bus and
not attack
you know we don't do we have 3300
members we don't do what every single
member tells us all of the time we are
pretty good at working everywhere the
bus routes should be okay come on us
come on that's Christian really oh is it
did you ever see the industry becoming
regulated yeah well my answer of course
is the industry is regulated so ignore
the regulator and replace that with
license these are elements yeah it's a
gonna be a point where you need to have
qualifications to be a recruitment
consultant so to advise clients or
candidates
it's my question I don't think that kind
of regulated profession piece you know
like a lawyer or a doctor would come in
I do think that I I think I do think
that a more robust form of quality
control is likely whether that's a
strengthened EAS as part of this new
single enforcement body or a really
interesting topic which is that Matthew
Taylor who will be the workplace for
forum report for Therese in May and is
no director of labor market enforcement
and therefore technically the employment
agency standards inspectors boss put a
couple of months ago which is how can we
take some of these industry codes that
we have you know you have to pass a
compliance test to be an AR EC member
and and how can we make sure they're
really robust and I think will come
under quite a lot of pressure from
government on that and not just as other
actors in the industry at school and
others to have a think about how we can
further invest in standards in the
industry after all of this with the
threat being that will license you if
not but I actually think that something
robust won by the industry is probably
better from clients and candidates
because it's just going to be more
relevant than something designed in
Whitehall yeah man just just equipment
Tony I'd love to get your saw apart and
worry because I think
you in the trenches right now UN
recruitment business I think it'd be
good to just get your thoughts on what
your netid is to your people but just
quick one-nil just before we finish so
Marian submitted a question which was
just really simple which was are are the
RAC running any surveys at the moment or
will be running these surveys on how
this is affecting or impacting agencies
that could be useful people to keep an
eye on we've got some flash surveys on
what the market is doing there's one
coming up Friday morning I'm where the
temp and the the poem markets currently
are obviously that has an impact on
agencies we are doing some surveys
pretty regularly both through at the
moment so that we stuff coming out over
the next few XP weeks okay cool
and Tony poem words mate what what's the
message that you're saying to you and
your people I think to look through it I
think it's really easy you know to look
at now what's happening and let somebody
knock backs at the moment with its
council interviews or pulling jobs I
think it's to look through it and build
your personal brand and your business
based on how it will look
post covert and I think there'll be a
lot of positives that come out of it for
the industry that we put in together
with you coming on this and all that
sort of stuff now you know people pull
it together for ideas and sharing
experiences and actually a slicker
recruitment process with companies
appreciating the value of recruiters and
the value of the process as well so I
think the only message of size look
through and look at what what it looks
like post kovaydin and yeah it's tough
at the moment there's a lot of knock
backs but we'll all be better free
longer-term awesome well look just want
to say thanks Neil for join the Nance
really appreciate your time being honest
with the audience Tony really enjoyed
this with you mate so thank the fact is
when I'm in your input and thanks
everyone for joining I was going to end
this now but really appreciate all of
your time and the edge it's a huge fan
let's keep going and we'll get through
this